Jon Stones is a world class Rob holding
but celba is a different oh my God you
having that don't even different Rob
holding in
the St a lot of people watch this you
that's
very disrespectful St you make me
disrespect I like stones CBA cannot do
what Stones does Stones can do what CBA
does Steve if CBA played instead of
stones you win the mentality B no chance
he bottles it he bottles it Todd B who
do you want him to call tomorrow for C
or manity that's no cuz Stones is
getting older so that's a bad argument
but what I'm saying is this is about
winning this is about winning isn't it
seen a picture of your team at the end
of the season with a dog and a charity
AR about the dog Sean Stones has got the
treble and the freedom of Manchester and
he wears a
KAG listen I don't even know what aoo is